mesdames et messieurs bonsoir le second
procès de guy turcotte pour le meurtre
de ses deux enfants va commencer
finalement demain au palais de justice
de saint girons me karen bastien
si on commet site on sait que l'étape de
la sélection du jury a été menée vue de
fait bien fait oui très rapide en moins
de quatre heures les 12 jurés ont été
choisis seraient peut être encore plus
rapide mais le juré numéro 3 a décidé de
demander une extension parce que son
mari a perdu son travail aujourd'hui
alors la dame annulée elle rit savoir
l'extension c'est pour cette raison que
ça a pris un peu plus de temps mais
quand même moins de quatre heures c'est
effectivement très rapide donne une idée
des jurés donc ces sept hommes cinq
femmes peut pas les nommer bien sûr ils
vont rester anonyme que vous donnez leur
profession par exemple on a une
secrétaire un retraité de l'enseignement
un ingénieur une esthéticienne courte
immobilier une serveuse employés de
magasins de grande surface donc ça vous
donne une idée des différents emplois
que cube
ces gens là on leur posait quatre
questions alors le juge leur demande
premièrement leur profession
deuxièmement s'il avait entendu parler
de la cause de guy turcotte s'ils
avaient une opinion c'est la troisième
question sur guy turcotte adresse clé
les coupes est-ce qu'il se sentait
coupable ou non coupable est la
quatrième question est la plus
importante
on leur demandait s'il pouvait mettre de
côté leurs opinions et devenir jurée
écouter la preuve est jugé monsieur
turcotte seulement sur la pop qui sera
entendue lors du procès alors voilà les
douze ont été choisis ça commence dès
demain et on leur demandait aussi
implicitement de mettre leur vie de côté
pour un long moment en passation un long
procès
effectivement un principe probablement
entre 2 et 3 mois
la couronne a fait savoir il ya un
classement dernière qu'elle allait
présenter une trentaine de témoins donc
effectivement ce sera très long mais ça
commence quand même rapidement dès
demain donc tout l'automne ça va se
rendre peut-être à noël peut-être avant
noël on verra mais effectivement ça sera
un très lourd poids c'est très bien car
et merci au revoir